[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau journal d'information
locale nous sommes le mercredi 15
septembre voici les titres de cette
édition
kg de bourguignon s'est rendu sur le
site d'airbus ce mardi à elancourt
l'occasion pour la ministre chargée de
l'autonomie de lancer une nouvelle
mission concernant la responsabilité
sociétale des entreprises objectif
amplifier le soutien aux salariés et
dont et faire connaître les dispositifs
existants à maurepas et coignières la
zone commerciale par west se refait une
beauté le but inclure une parenthèse
verte et responsable l'exemple dans ce
journal avec l'un des projets retenus et
ixia nous recevrons également didier
fischer vice-président délégué au
commerce pour parler de cette
modernisation et puis pour
l'environnement les douze communes de
l'agglomération s'engage pour nettoyer
saint quentin en yvelines une opération
qui s'inscrit dans le cadre du world
cleanapp d au programme un massage des
déchets sensibilisation à la cause
environnementale
[Musique]
c'est l'un des gros projets des années à
venir la ligne 18 qui doit relier
versailles à l'aéroport d'orly est en
marche pour rappel la première partie en
essonne de la ligne devrait voir le jour
en 2000 26 pour les y est bein il faudra
attendre jusqu'en 2030 ce mardi 14
septembre le premier tunnelier a été
baptisé à palaiseau et bixente mais rien
senti steban étaient sur place il
s'appelle céline en référence à l'une
des collaboratrices du projet et
marraine de la machine le premier
tunnelier de la ligne 18 a été baptisé
ce mardi 14 septembre à palaiseau un
événement fait selon les traditions c
une somme de travail assez considérable
qui permet d'aboutir à cette
inauguration
elle est symbolique aussi parce que il
se trouve que les tunneliers sont des
professions dur et qui attache beaucoup
d'importance aux traditions mais il
faudra encore patienter quelques
semaines pour que la première pierre
soit brisée par l'immense machine les
simples opérations de montage un
tunnelier qui fait 100 mètres de long
milliers de tonnes sont des opérations
très complexe qui sont évidemment me et
en lien avec les ingénieurs de la
société qui fabrique ce tunnelier prévue
pour 2026 cette première portion entre
orly et palaiseau est bel et bien en
route le début de 35 km de métro
automatique qui passera dans les
yvelines dans les yvelines on aura
plusieurs séquences on a une partie la
ligne 18 qui en aérien donc la
technologie sera différente c'est
quelque chose de beaucoup plus simple on
a une partie en tranchée couverte qui
sera creusé depuis la surface et puis on
aura une partie en tunnels creusés au
tunnelier entre saint quentin s est le
terminus de l'année 18 en 2030 qui sera
à versailles chantiers pour la portion
yvelinoise du projet et les gares de
saint quentin est satory et versailles
chantiers il faudra encore patienter les
travaux dans les yvelines commenceront
en 2023 petite vitesse d'abord et
prendre leur essor vraiment imprévue les
jeux olympiques de 2024 donc le mois
d'octobre 2024 le tunnelier devrait
démarrer dans ces eaux là la ligne 18
finalisé entièrement en 2030 prévoit 110
milles voyages quotidiens à travers les
yvelines l'essonne et les hauts-de-seine
aider les entreprises à se mobiliser
pour soutenir leurs salariés et dont
c'est l'objectif du déplacement de
brigitte bourguignon accompagné des
secrétaires d'état sophie cluzel et
olivia grégoire la ministre est chargé
de l'autonomie s'est rendu ce mardi 14
septembre sillage est d'airbus defense
and space à elancourt au programme le
lancement d'une mission de la plateforme
rse responsabilité sociétale à des
entreprises un reportage avec céline
charles ils sont 11 millions en france
accompagnez au quotidien un proche en
situation de maladie de perte
d'autonomie ou de handicap les aidants
bref bien souvent concilier travail et
vie personnelle le gouvernement a confié
à l'occasion d'un déplacement sur le
site d'airbus à elancourt la mission
d'encourager les entreprises à se
mobiliser en faveur de ses salariés et
d'en prendre conscience que cette
politique est gagnant gagnant pour
l'entreprise pour que les collaborateurs
soit le plus sereinement possible
à leur tâche mais en même temps qu'il
puisse avoir cette conciliation vie
professionnelle vie personnelle c'est
ainsi que l'on veut travailler c'est
pour ça qu'on missionne vraiment cette
plateforme air est ce nous avons lancé
cette mission auprès d'eux
france stratégie pardon la plateforme
airs et ce parce que nous voulons que
les entreprises nous aident à promouvoir
cette politique d'accompagnement des
aidants par le congé absentéisme
dégradation de l'état de santé des
motivations la mission a comme objectif
de lutter contre ces dommages en faisant
connaître et en facilitant les
politiques d'accompagnement en la
matière airbus fait figure d'exemple
l'entreprise a déjà mis en place une
série de dispositifs visant à soutenir
les employés aidant on a souhaité mettre
en place une formation qui permet de
connaître
les dispositions les dispositifs qui
peut qui peuvent s'offrir à lui ou à
elle également on a une application qui
permet d'y regrouper différents
dispositifs et ainsi donner une
visibilité à ces mesures des mesures
importantes pour que les salariés et
dans ce centre considéré dans un monde
du travail où on est dans une culture
quand même delà de la performance
absolue pour la reconnaissance quelque
part il faut qu'on puisse imaginer un
dispositif intelligent qui prennent en
compte justement une situation familiale
difficile temporaire est particulière et
que cette situation mais neutralisent
justement tous les critères de
reconnaissance qui rend derrière la
mission de la plateforme rse se
terminera d'ici le 1er février 2022 et
sera par la suite présenté au
gouvernement
[Musique]
et la zone paris ouest de maurepas
coignières a amorcé son processus de
changement le pôle commercial vieux de
50 ans doit être réinséré dans la partie
urbaine entièrement privé la zone ne
compte pas moins de 180 propriétaire à
différents soit des difficultés
supplémentaires pour cette modernisation
globale un premier volet de ce grand
changement a déjà débuté avec le
programme et ixia le reportage de
nicolas landry et bixente mais rien
senti steban
l'objectif est vraiment de relier le
coeur historique de maurepas avec ses
frangins agricole pour véritablement
faire payer la nature dans la ville et
dans le projet le programme et ixia
c'est le premier exemple du renouveau de
la zone d'activités paris ouest à
maurepas le projet mené en deux phases a
débuté par le déménagement de
l'enseignent kiabi dans des nouveaux
locaux sur ces premières étapes vous
avez fait concrètement la mutation donc
d'une d'une ancienne qui était jadis qui
habille le magasin kiabi qui s'est
transféré juste en face avec un
découpage en quatre autres cellules donc
in fine et vous avez cinq cellules sur
la première étape on a mixé à la fois
des enseignes nationales et des porteurs
de projets plus à plus locaux trois des
quatre enseignes qui seront présentes
sont déjà connus afflelou chausséa et
die by day et xl et dans la tente d'un
dernier entrepreneurs pour compléter
l'espace le parking et la zone de
déchets seront communs pour les cinq
magasins
l'objectif est de mutualiser tous sains
et d'euros de rendre véritablement les
partis pris et la place primordiale de
l'humain dans son usage et dansons dans
sa consommation d face d'où là d'où
l'importance du marqueur végétal qui va
dominer ou si le projet le projet dans
son intégralité
superviser et accompagnés par les maires
de maurepas et coignières grégory
gastier et didier fischer ce premier
projet s'inscrit dans une vision plus
large des zones commerciales paris-ouest
forum jb et porte de chevreuse les
autres zones d'activités économiques se
rassemblent d'ailleurs dans le dans le
secteur nous on souhaite vraiment avoir
un positionnement différent différent
puisqu'on est à la lisière de forêt de
zones agricoles importantes notamment
sur sur coignières on a le village de
maurepas qui est pas loin donc d'avoir
une identité très forte un
positionnement qu'on se sente bien dans
cette zone d'activités avec ses vingt
mille mètres carrés le programme éthique
serre ne représente pourtant que 18% de
la zone paris ouest le plus grand espace
d'activités de l'ouest parisien
et pour continuer à parler de ce sujet
la modernisation du pôle commercial
paris-ouest nous recevront en plateau
didier fischer du soir bonsoir donc vous
êtes président délégué au commerce est
aussi maire de coignières et jean-michel
bien sûr du coup là la zone commerciale
est situé sur les communes de coignières
est mort pas exactement
alors cette modernisation elle s'inscrit
dans le cadre d'un projet qui était
repenser la périphérie commerciale elle
avait été lancée par l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines en 2019 suite
à une étude en fait qu'est-ce qui était
ressort alors on avait répondu en fait
un appel à projets donc du ministère de
la cohésion des territoires on avait été
retenu six lauréats donc et on a fait
partie des six lauréats ce qui était
déjà une reconnaissance pour le travail
qu'ils avaient déjà été entamés par la
commune de maurepas et de coignières sur
le sujet qui est une véritable
requalification finalement d'une zone
d'activités d'ailleurs je devrais dire
de trois zones d'activité puisqu'il
s'agit de paris-ouest forum gibet donc
si tu es là sur coignières et les portes
de chevreuse alors c'est une zone qui
représente 108 hectares
c'est considérable alors cela nous a
permis donc d'engager une étude qui
n'est pas encore tout à fait terminée
donc c'est pour ça que les conclusions
les dernières conclusions les apprends
encore mais elle est déjà bien entamé
une étude où on a travaillé sur un
diagnostic dans un premier temps ensuite
sur une stratégie commerciale urbaine a
adopté un schéma de cohérence en fait
urbaine aussi été mis en place et là on
est sur des zooms ce qu'on appelle la
quatrième phase les zooms pré
opérationnelles c'est-à-dire qu'on
essaye de voir sur paris ouest hélas le
projet et ixia dont on a vu tout à
l'heure quelques images et donc le
projet etics ya lui et dans ce cadre là
c'est à dire dans les 48 hectares du
zoom paris ouest et vous avez aussi 40
hectares deuxième zoom sur forum gilles
beck est une zone d'activité aujourd'hui
je dirais vieillissante aussi un comme
l'était paris ouest et c'est pour cela
que l'on est dans cette opération de
requalification donc de nos zones
d'activités et donc il va y avoir aussi
une nouvelle dimension notamment avec
cette étude qui sera tourné par l'éco
responsabilité avec la création des
espaces verts installations aussi des
deux boutiques vrac ou en circuit court
c'était une demande des clients ah bien
sûr oui c'était une demande quand je
vous disais tout à l'heure on avait fait
le diagnostic on avait travaillé à la
stratégie on l'a travaillait avec les
habitants avec les partenaires
économiques du secteur
et il en était ressorti en effet cette
demande aujourd'hui les modes de
consommation ont changé ou sont en train
de changer on voit bien que le modèle
ses zones d'activité c'était un modèle
des années 70-80 passé plus tellement
d'actualité les consommateurs veulent
autre chose ils veulent y trouver du
plaisir à faire leurs courses ils
veulent évoluer dans un milieu qu'ils
soient plutôt sympathique et d'où la
nécessité de re nature et de reverdir
finalement ces espaces de désintermédiés
lisez les sols et d'y amener aussi des
circulations douces donc un tout autre
univers que celui qui existe aujourd'hui
et là on est vraiment en train de
repenser quelque chose qui n'est pas
seulement le disait requalifier mais qui
n'est pas seulement une requalification
finalement de zones d'activités on est
bien en train de repenser la ville de
demain là vous disais tout à l'heure la
zone commerciale à presque 50 ans
c'était important de renouveler cette
stratégie commerciale notamment quel est
l'objectif est ce que c'est finalement
augmenter la fréquentation du lieu oui
aussi c'est à dire que dans notre
stratégie l'idée c'est de je dirais de
rendre ce lieu encore plus attractif
qu'il ne l'est aujourd'hui parce qu'en
fait si on attend trop sur nos
requalifie pas si on attend trop dans
dix ans c'est fini dans dix ans on va
voir des friches commerciales
industrielles un petit peu partout donc
c'est ça qu'il faut qu'on évite donc il
faut effectivement retravailler à
l'attractivité commerciale et
l'attractivité commerciale l ai dit
aussi à la qualité de vie sur le site et
c'est bien pour cela qu'il faut aussi
d'une certaine manière créer une
relation entre le milieu vous savez vous
connaissez cet espace le milieu
environnant c'est la nature en
définitive ce sont des chances et c'est
la forêt à proximité
et aujourd'hui ces zones d'activités
vivent quelque sorte tournés vers elle
même donc il faut ouvrir vers les champs
s'ouvrir vers la nature et donc fait
rentrer en quelque sorte la nature dans
ces espaces commerciaux et là on va
passer en fait deux zones qui sont
monofonctionnel à une mixité
fonctionnelle il met même de l'habitat
bien entendu avec du commerce de
proximité par exemple en pied d'immeuble
voilà voilà un peu le projet et
l'ambition qu'on a que les élus porte je
porte cette ambition évidemment avec les
élus de saint quentin en yvelines et
notamment avec mon collègue grégory
garris yeke maire de maurepas il ya donc
plusieurs appels à projets on a vu
l'exemple tout à l'heure avec et ixia si
on l'a entendu représenterez finalement
seulement 18% de paris-ouest donc il y
aura d'autres projets ce que vous avez
une idée un peu du nombre de projets qui
pourrait y avoir comment ils ont été
retenus quels ont été les critères alors
pour l'instant il n'y a pas d'autres
projets retenus 1 c'est à dire qu'on est
en réflexion on est en réflexion mais il
est évident que et ixia et je dirai ce
qui est en train de se faire là cette
parenthèse verte comme l'appelle et ixia
et bien c'est en quelque sorte le
premier projet qui sort c'est le premier
projet alors je dirais c'est plus facile
parce qu'en fait ce qu'il faut bien
avoir à l'esprit c'est qu'on a trois
zones d'activités avec 183 propriétaire
ce qui n'est pas simple pour maîtriser
le foncier c'est compliqué c'est
compliqué la maîtrise du foncier c'est
très compliqué donc l'idée et ixia nous
aussi en ce qui concerne qu'est la
foncière au chant et ixia c'est plus la
foncière kiabi
ce sont des grosses structures qui
maîtrisait déjà un espace relativement
important plusieurs hectares sur place
donc c'était plus facile de commencer
par là en définitive et le projet et
ixia s'inscrit dans le schéma de
cohérence urbaine que nous avons
adoptées nous les nous les élus donc
d'une certaine manière c'est la première
vraie man la première réalisation qui
est en train de sortir de terre et vous
pouvez vous pouvez le voir vous l'avez
vu d'une certaine façon c'est une autre
façon de penser finalement la démarche
commerciale on n'est plus dans
l'agressivité commerciale on est
beaucoup plus aussi dans le commerce de
conseil on voit bien les commerces qui
vont s'installer il ya débat il est par
exemple qu'est dubrac voilà voilà un
beau projet voilà un beau projet porté
par un commerçant qui on veut en quelque
sorte le rang sec et qui je pense
va réaliser quelque chose de beau et de
grand
sur cette zone d'activités aussi est-ce
que vous pouvez peut-être nous rappeler
le calendrier des travaux à venir
concernant cette zone quand est ce que
les premiers travaux nouveau débuter et
quand alors sur la zone c'est à dire
côté et ixia les travaux ont déjà débuté
cc 2021 là on va bientôt inaugurer
une première tranche il y aura une
deuxième tranche 2024 ensuite à la fin
de l'étude c'est là qu'on va voir
comment on va pouvoir phase et un après
je dirais la transformation de la zone
mais ça sera long c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui on est dans une
perspective à 2035 on avait parlé 2030
au départ dont les plus tôt à 2035 voire
2040 pourquoi parce que déjà il ya cette
complicité foncière il faut faire avec
et
ça sera pas simple à transformer
progressivement cet espace mais ça va se
faire ça va se faire parce qu on le fait
en concertation parce que on travaille
avec tous les partenaires du dieu donc
je pense qu'on devrait y arriver en plus
le disait hier notamment à la conférence
de presse
il ya une vraie volonté politique des
élus des élus ne mord pas des élus de
coignières de transformer cette zone
donc ça c'est ça qui compte souvent il
faut cette force si c'est pas porté
politiquement ça marche pas c'est clair
très bien merci beaucoup didier fischer
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir elle
comprit je le rappelle vous êtes
vice-président délégué au commerce merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous je vous
en prie
[Musique]
le 18 septembre c'est le retour du world
qui nappe dès lors de cette journée des
opérations de nettoyage ont lieu dans le
monde entier à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
des opérations auront lieu pendant le
week end les douze communes de
l'agglomération se sont engagés l
interview de joséphine coleman bergé
vice présidente en charge de
l'environnement et de la transition
écologique pour l'agglomération c'était
au micro de ses biens 400 go
[Musique]
j'ai fait la proposition cette année est
bien de gros groupes et le workglop des
pour l'ensemble plutôt que chaque ville
phase rendant dans son coin même si on
continue à faire ça mais malgré tout de
réunir 7 cet événement avec un
chapeautage on va dire entre guillemets
de communication de 51 movie et tout le
monde a accepté donc c'est super bien
parce qu'il y en a qui commencent eux 10
l d'eau de 18 19 mai c'est sur le même
week-end
[Musique]
c'est une forme de prise de conscience
elle est double cette prise de
conscience et une prise de conscience de
nettoyage bien sûr puisque avec des
pinces et des gants on va aller ramasser
les déchets mais ensuite il ya le crime
qui va se faire c'est à dire qu'on va
avoir un moment de collecte à chaque
point d'arrivée et ensuite ya un prix
derrière qui va se faire
le principe c'est de partir d'un point
où on a un regroupement de personnes à
qui on distribue le matériel qui met qui
s'affuble bien sûr des gilets pour qu'on
puisse les repérer ne serait-ce qu'au
niveau de la sécurité et ensuite il ya
des circuits qui sont prévues il essaye
de faire un nettoyage il n'y a pas de
concours sur pour savoir qui en a
ramassé le plus mais en règle générale
on pèse bien sûr à la fin de
l'expérience pour savoir combien on a pu
récupérer deux kilos vous l'aurez
compris le world kindness day c'est donc
une initiative pour sensibiliser au
ramassage des déchets et à leur tri pour
l'occasion une opération à lui en avant
première ce mardi 14 septembre
l'association je respecte ma ville et
l'école maternelle paul fort à montigny
le bretonneux ont sensibilisé elle est
plus petit antoine durand s'est rendu
sur place
ce mardi les enfants de montigny le
bretonneux partent à la chasse aux
détritus l'école paul-fort a organisé
cette activité afin de sensibiliser ses
élèves au ramassage des déchets notre
école dans son projet de développement
durable est très attaché à la notion de
biodiversité
donc on a un jardin
une serre et on travaille dans la nature
en permanence et donc la nature il faut
la protéger ramasser des déchets en fait
partie équipés de gants de sacs et de
pinces aucun détritus n'a pu résister
face aux parents et à cette jeunesse
motivée
très bel engagement déjà de l'école de
participer à ce genre d'action est chez
vu des enfants très motivés à ramasser
les petites échelles
piqué bien qu'ils me ramasser des
déchets
clame déchets mes mains des chais qui
coupent est-ce que la bière fédé et les
plastiques dans cette poubelle
accompagnés par l'association je
respecte ma ville les enfants ont pu
découvrir le fonctionnement du tri
sélectif c'est à lui qu'appartient
demandé dès demain nous on est juste la
génération qui prend conscience et les
élèves et les plus jeunes c'est alors
qu'on est seulement de demandes et
besoins cet événement organisé afin de
toucher le plus d'enfants et de parents
annoncent le lancement de la nouvelle
saison du world food day qui se
déroulera le 18 septembre
côté culture moins connue que celle du
patrimoine les journées du patrimoine se
déroulent également ce week-end
l'objectif est double proposer des
rendez vous culturels et travailler en
faveur de l'égalité hommes femmes dans
le domaine de l'art l'événement met en
avant les artistes féminines du passé au
travers du théâtre de conférences ou
encore de spectacles dans les yvelines
vous avez rendez vous samedi 18
septembre à la villa simone signoret à
guyancourt ce sera pour une déambulation
sonore autour des noms féminins de la
ville plus d'informations sur le site
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran et c'est
la fin de cette édition du 7 8 journal
merci à tous de nous avoir suivi dans
quelques instants vous retrouverez
mélanie poké à la présentation du 7-8
société très bonne soirée à tous sur tv
[Musique]